the danger of AI is much greater than
the danger of nuclear warheads by a lot
and nobody would suggest that we allow
anyone to just build nuclear warheads if
they want that would be insane and mark
my words
AI is far more dangerous than nukes
far so why do we have no regulatory
oversight this is insane
but I think we should also be cautious
about Ai and just make sure that as we
develop AI that it is you know it
doesn't get out of control and and that
uh that the AI helps make the future
better for Humanity people call it the
singularity and that's that's probably a
great thing about it is it's a singular
it's hard to predict like a black hole
what what happens past the Event Horizon
from a long-term existential standpoint
that's like the
purpose of neurolink is to create a high
bandwidth interface to the brain such
that we can be symbiotic with AI
because we have a bandwidth problem you
just can't communicate through fingers
is too slow it's going to come faster
than anyone appreciates I think it's
with each passing year the
sophistication of computer intelligence
is
growing dramatically I mean I really
think we're on an exponential
Improvement path of artificial
intelligence and the number of smart
humans that are developing AI is also
increasing dramatically I mean if you'll
get like the attendance at the AI
conferences they're they're doubling
every year
um they're getting full
well I think it's best to prepare for to
try to prevent a negative circumstance
from occurring than to wait for it to
occur and then be reactive so and this
is a case where the potential the range
of negative outcomes some of them are
quite severe so it's not clear whether
we'd be able to recover from some of
these negative negative outcomes in fact
some of the certainly can construct
scenarios where
recovery of human civilization does not
occur and when the risk is that severe
it seems like you should be proactive
and not reactive I think that's going to
be tricky here is that it's going to be
very tempting to use AI as a weapon it's
going to be very tempting in fact we'll
be used as a weapon the danger is going
to be more humans using it against each
other I think most likely that'll be the
danger
yeah I try to convince people to slow
down
slow down AI
to regulate AI
this was futile I tried for years I'm
always to some degree wrong
um and the aspiration is to be less
wrong
we're always to some degree wrong well
it doesn't matter who you are
and
I think Trying to minimize
um the wrong-headedness over time is is
that I believe in that philosophy those
are great things those are things that
make me like the future and or be
inspired about the future
um
whereas if those things don't happen the
future I think looks quite dumb
um and um and I just feel quite
fortunate that we've made the progress
that we have on those fronts and we will
aspire to make more progress in the
future I met with Congress
meeting of all 50 governors
and talked about AI danger and I talked
to everyone I could I wouldn't seem to
realize where this was going
I'm really quite close to I'm very close
to The Cutting Edge in Ai and it scares
the hell out of me it's capable of
vastly more than almost anyone knows
and the rate of improvement is
exponential
the rate of improvement is really
dramatic but we have to figure out some
way to ensure that the Advent of digital
super intelligence is one which is
symbiotic with Humanity I think that's
single biggest existential crisis that
we face and the most pressing one I'm
not normally an advocate of Regulation
and oversight I mean I think once you
generally you're on the side of
minimizing those things but this is a
case where you have a very serious
danger to the public and therefore there
needs to be a public body that has
insight and then oversight on to confirm
that everyone is
developing AI safely
when I made this comment some years ago
but it feels like we are the biological
Bootloader for AI effectively we are
building it and then we're building
progressively greater intelligence and
the percentage of intelligence that is
not human is increasing and eventually
we will represent a very small
percentage of intelligence the AI is a
rare case where I think we need to be
proactive in regulation instead of
reactive because I think by the time we
are reactive in AI regulation it's too
late and normally the way regulations
are set up is that a whole bunch of bad
things happen there's a public outcry
the the and then after many years a
regulatory agency is set up to regulate
that industry and there's a bunch of
opposition from companies the biggest
issue I see with so-called AI experts is
that they think they know more than they
do
and I think they're smarter than they
actually are they don't like the idea
that a machine could be way smarter than
them so they discount the idea which is
fundamentally flawed That's The Wishful
Thinking situation AI is a fundamental
risk to the existence of human
civilization in a way that car accidents
uh airplane crashes
um faulty drugs or bad food we're not
they were not they were harmful to to a
set of individuals within Society of
course but they were not awful to
society as a whole AI is a fundamental
existential risk for human civilization
I don't think most people understand
just how quickly machine intelligence is
advancing it's much faster than almost
anyone realizes even within Silicon
Valley and certainly outside Silicon
Valley people really have no idea if
there's some digital super intelligence
um and
it's optimization or utility function is
something that's detrimental to humanity
then it will have a very bad effect
I think people should be really
concerned about it I keep soundingly
long Bell but you know until
people see like robots going down the
street killing people like they don't
know how to react you know because it
seems so ethereal
um
and I think we should be really
concerned about AI I mean most of the
movies and TV featuring AI they don't
describe it in quite the way it's likely
to actually take place but I think you
just have to consider like even in the
benign scenario where if AI is much
smarter than a person
um what what do we do
what what is that what job do we have um
well I like the definition of like the
eyes should try to maximize the freedom
of action of humanity
um
maximize the freedom of action
maximize Freedom essentially it's
important if we have this incredible
power of AI that if not be concentrated
in the hands of a few and potentially
lead to a world that we don't want so I
think we must have democratization of AI
technology and make it widely available
um and that's you know the reason that
obviously uh you mean the rest of the
team you know created open AI was to
help with the Democracy help help spread
out AI technology so it doesn't get
concentrated in the hands of a few now
if we do have a third layer which is the
AI extension of yourself if you assume
any rate of advancement in AI
um
we will be left behind by a lot so far
below them in intelligence that it would
be would be like you know a pet
[Music]